that movie was amazing  hey dad imagine if zorro came riding  through gotham on his horse right now  well bruce i'm not so sure a masked  vigilante would be welcomed in gotham  city  sadly they'd probably just lock someone  like zorro and arkham  those were his last words to me lately  i've been wondering  if he was right i had years and you  alfred to help me come to terms with the  murder of my parents  but i must have been crazy to put jason  in the field before he'd recovered from  his loss  his father murdered by two-face his  mother succumbing to illness his actions  as  robin are guided by unresolved pain and  anger  he's a danger to himself a danger to our  mission  i have no choice jason's going off  active duty immediately  fine with me jason  jason  you